what is your middle name matt gourley
you are matt you still score
matthew matt eustace gourley no no no no
james gourley matt
eustis
hezekiah
uh what is that what do you got is that
the shirt that's a baby stretcher yeah
what are you saying
what is that
it's just something you put next to your
baby to try to get it be quiet
it just stretches them and so
why don't you just go shush that's all
it's doing it's doing what you can do
just go out you and your wife can go out
and get food and leave this behind
well why don't you just leave get like a
michelin tire put an ice pick through it
and let it hiss at your baby
well you and your wife hit the bar scene
i don't understand why you need that
thing that things seem and that's not
comforting that's not
that's
there's a reason it's in here with me
and not being used
terrible it looks like a salt and pepper
shaker yeah but when you turn the knob
it makes your baby think that there's an
asp in the bed with it
ready to strike at her jugular that's
terrible
well i think he was using it
now for a different reason yeah it
wasn't working no i can talk right
through that i don't need that that's
not that wouldn't have worked in my
house growing up let me tell you six
apes six irish apes running around
smashing into each other red-headed
orangutans no i was the only redhead but
i was a redheaded orangutan with with
five other apes all of us smashing and
crashing into each other in a confined
space
my father of course always at the lab
he'd always say wait
sure the lad was a cocktail bar yes
exactly
trust me
trust me he's not even a doctor he he
bought a white coat
[Laughter]
he bought he took a white coat off of an
ice cream vendor and uh said he was a
doctor and was just gone all the time
and my poor mother would just be trying
to get us all to
be quiet and just settle down and
nothing
ever worked
you know what i'm picturing you know
that scene in zoolander where they're
like jumping on the computer trying to
open it up and they're just a bunch of
monkeys i just picture six of those just
running around jumping on things and
making weird like grunting noises yeah
no it was uh my mom did everything she
could to
get us to settle down and uh it didn't
work and
once my mother and father they never got
to go out to dinner first of all in
boston in the 70s i think there was one
restaurant you know
within 30 miles of our house and uh it
was something like like the jolly roger
yeah exactly it had
um and it was this restaurant that my it
was tony's italian villa
[Laughter]
and it was not even a restaurant and it
was on and it was on route 9.
tony's italian villain
tony's italian villa was on route 9
and my poor folks it was the one
restaurant they could take us to and
they could afford it because we'd all
cram into one booth and it had one of
those mini jukeboxes at the end of the
table one of those mini ones yeah
nothing says italian restaurant like a
mini yeah and my and
my brother would always put whatever it
was back then a nickel into it and play
american pie because the song lasted
longer than any other song so i was
sitting there at tony's italian villa
which by the way had these terrible
paintings on the wall of like the
parthenon
and and anthony quinn
and zach galifianakis all greek yeah
anything greek mike dukakis olympia
dukakis uh mount dukakis and and
we'd sit there and you'd hear and i just
associate them they knew they served one
thing which was pizza
they'd bring us a pizza and we'd each
get one soda we were allowed one soda we
never got to drink soda because my dad's
a doctor we never got to drink soda
except when we went to tony's italian
villa and we each got one soda and the
nickel would go in long long time ago
i can still remember and you'll be like
oh my god here we go this song goes on
for nine minutes and neil would say yeah
but it's a nickel dad did he want to get
his nickels worth that's why he just
wanted as much so every time i was like
i didn't know what possible it was chevy
to the levee and i didn't know what a
levee was
and i remembered i'd sit there waiting
for the pizza which we always got
and we'd get our we would each get our
one coke which wasn't very much coke it
was a narrow glass and i'll never forget
the time my brother neal
said hey i'll race you to see who can
drink their coke first and i went okay
and he said go and i just inhaled the
coke instantly and neil didn't even take
a sip
brutal and my coke for the for not just
the week maybe the month
was gone
and nia was just laughing at me with
these that is with his
big donkey laugh he was like
and then i heard drove my chevy to the
living but
and that guy would come over and be like
you want your pizza pie
you're like can you at least pretend to
be italian
this story is somehow depressing
guess what i still whenever i go back
and see my parents
i always if i if i'm driving in um you
know from anywhere and i'm driving on
route 9 i pass
the building that used to be tony's
italian villa because it's long gone a
long long long time ago i can still
remember when
olympia dukakis was on the wall
and the three men i admired most the
father the sun and the garlic toast they
looked a bit in dim light like donnie
most the day the pizza pied
do you want to leave i yeah i have that
so i wanted you guys to understand my
childhood